back before x-men spider-man and the
marvel cinematic universe the superhero
genre was a pretty tough nut to crack
now hollywood has mostly got it figured
out but it didn't always used to be this
way here are some of the weirder early
attempts we could have gotten
some rainy spider-man series may look a
little acquainted by today's standards
but when the first film dropped in 2002
it hit like a minor miracle
the flick enjoyed the biggest opening
weekend ever at the time
validating raimi's lifelong dream of
bringing a comic book hero to life his
1990 cult classic dark man with a super
heroic character of his own creation
was a result of the director being
rebuffed to every time in his bid to
adapt an existing comic book property
such as the shadow or batman after that
film's relative success
reimy figured he had some creative
capital to spend when beloved marvel
mastermind stan lee died in late 2018
raymie shared a story about what could
have been with the hollywood reporter
after i did darkman stanley called me
and was like hey kid i liked your movie
he took me out to lunch and said we
should work together
raymie said he told lee that he'd like
to make a movie about thor who had
previously only appeared in live action
form and the tv movie the incredible
hulk returns
turns out the people who owned the film
rights of the character weren't ready
for another try just yet
according to raymie we worked together
writing treatments and took it to fox
and pitched it and they said
absolutely no comic books don't make
good movies this was in 1991
it would take raymie another eight years
to land the gig of his dreams and it's
safe to say that he acquitted himself
pretty well
enough said as well received as sam
raimi's first two spider-man films were
2007 spider-man 3 wasn't particularly
problematic was the plot line of eddie
brock and the famous venom symbiote
which raymie didn't even want to include
in the movie in the first place but
while the venom storyline may have felt
pretty tacked on the movie as a whole
does have its moments
how's the pain so
good toe for grace's take and the parker
hating brock was actually pretty good
the problem was the character of the
venom symbiote itself
i like being bad
it makes me happy despite the negative
reception to venom's live-action debut
sony celeb plans to develop a spin-off
starring grace's version of the
character
according to the hollywood reporter the
studio was inspired to move forward with
the more villainous sort of anti-hero
project after the rapturous reception to
heath ledger's joker
in 2008's the dark knight multiple
script drafts were written for the venom
spinoff project but the whole plan went
out the window when sony decided to
reboot the spider-man franchise and
start over with the amazing spider-man
series
who knows what grace would have done
with the whole movie of his own to work
with especially since he's expressed
confusion about why he was ever cast for
the role in the first place
2008's iron man was a film that launched
the highest grossing franchise in
history
but tony stark's live-action debut could
have easily looked a lot different
by the time marvel studios was formed in
2005 it had reacquired the rights to the
character
but those rights have spent years being
passed around from fox to universal to
new line with names attached to the
project including stuart gordon quentin
tarantino and even the iron giant
screenwriter tim mckinley's presumably
just because of the word iron in 2004 a
script from the creators of the
smallville tv series
landed in the lap of david hater whose
writing credits include the screenplays
of the first two x-men movies
haters set about reworking the
screenplay with contributions that
included making a villain out of tony's
father howard stark hater's version went
so far as to have the character align
himself with justin hammer to become
none other than
war machine you're dead then writes
holder new line and loved haters version
and set the project up with an
unconventional choice of director
nick casavettis whose biggest success to
that point was a romantic drama the
notebook
cassavetes was formally announced to be
helming the flick in 2004 with new line
aiming for a summer 2006 release
the studio had reason to be optimistic
they had spun box office gold from a
marvel property with the blade franchise
and thanks in part to haters x-men
flicks
superhero movies had recently become
surprisingly viable but the project
languished in development long enough
for marvel to get tony stark's rights
back in 2005
and the rest is history luke cage aka
harlem's own invincible powerman wasn't
the first black hero in comics
or even in marvel law but he immediately
earned a high profile by
virtue of a colorful costume a
formidable power set and an awesome
catchphrase
sweet christmas
his inspired pairing with super powered
martial artist iron fist sold a lot of
books in the 70s but before mike coulter
put his live-action stamp on the
character with a self-titled netflix
series
only one honest attempt has been made to
bring the human wrecking ball to the
screen
in 2003 columbia pictures optioned the
character for a film adaptation
hiring scribe ben ramsey to pen a
screenplay attached to helm the project
was john singleton whose incendiary
films boys in the hood and higher
learning
had established him as a talented
director capable of crafting masterful
black-centric stories
that were accessible to a wide audience
his dream casting tyrese gibson as cage
and terence howard as a villain
diamondback
the project eventually withered on the
vine with the rights reverting to marvel
in 2013
but before they did an even more
interesting name was floating for the
title role
idris elba who told the huffington post
in 2013 that he had briefly considered
taking on the part
the flash is bound to get his big screen
due with a solo movie any time now but
for the moments the scarlet speedster is
mostly enjoying a high profile thanks to
his well-received live-action series
in the cw's arrowverse warner brothers
has been attempting to get some kind of
version of a flash movie off the block
since at least 2004.
it was around that time that audiences
came close to getting a version
written produced and directed by batman
begin screenwriter david s goyer
at the time goya called the flash's
favorite of all the dc properties and
shared his plans to use the wally west
version of the character
instead of barry allen goyer said his
script was close in tone to the sam
raimi spider-man series and he felt ryan
reynolds would be perfect for the role
but the project was cut
short by creative differences by early
2007
goya had departed the project saying in
one interview the studio is heading off
in a completely different direction
i expect you'll hear some new
developments on that front shortly
the reality is not so much but
considering how many writers and
directors the flashpoint movie has gone
through over the years
it's not for lack of trying danny ran
the immortal iron fist has yet to get
his shutter a big screen adaptation
and his ill-fated small screen outing
which limped through two very poorly
received seasons on netflix probably
never should have happened
i'm the immortal iron fist come again
sworn protector of conlon what are you
on lithium
but in 2000 artisan entertainment which
at the time held the rights to a number
of marvel characters was dead set on
producing a feature vehicle for the
relatively little known character
and the project made a surprising amount
of headway before biting the dust
writer john turman who would go on to
pen angley's hulk as well as an
unproduced screenplay based on the
silver surfer
was hired to write the script and
artisan even got far enough into
development to cast their lead
scottish martial artist ray park
officially signed on to portray rand in
late 2000
and principal photography was slated to
begin early the following year
if you don't know him by name you've
still definitely seen his face at least
underneath a lot of scary makeup the
actor displayed a formidable screen
presence in the role of darth maul in
star wars episode 1 the phantom menace
and also made waves an ex-menace of
flexible and grotesque toad but though
park was still talking about the project
as late as 2004
it simply failed to materialize the
rights eventually reverted back to
marvel studios which briefly kicked
around the idea of an iron fist feature
in 2010 before the fateful decision was
made to go to cereal route instead
who is your master i serve only myself
prepare to disappoint you master 2018's
black panther was the highest grossing
film of that year and a bonafide
cultural phenomenon few people predicted
the movie's incredible success
except perhaps wesley snipes who had
envisioned exactly that scenario over 25
years before
in 1992 the red hot star was dead set on
making black panther
his next starring vehicle in a 2018
conversation with the hollywood reporter
snipe said black panther spoke to me
because he was noble and he was the
anti-thesis of the stereotypes presented
and portrayed about africans
african history and the great kingdoms
of africa he had cultural significance
social significance it was something
that the black community and the white
community hadn't seen before
snipes tried in vain to find the right
pairing of writer and director for the
project
a task made even more difficult by the
fact that virtually nobody understood
the character
an ill-fated meeting of director john
singleton illustrated that in hilarious
fashion
as snipes explained to thr john was like
nah haha
see he's got the spirit of the black
panther but is he trying to get his son
to join the black panther organization
and he and his son have a problem and
they have some strife because he's
trying to be politically correct and his
son wants to be a knucklehead
he's not a condom on top of people not
understanding that then obscure
superhero
cgi limitations at the time were also a
factor as the star was intent on
rendering wakanda in much the same way
as ryan coogler eventually did the
project lost steam
but snipes learned from the failure
instead he moved on to a different
marvel comics project blade
as snipes recalled i thought hey we
can't do the king of wakanda and the
vibranium and the hidden kingdom in
africa let's do a black vampire
that groundbreaking project came
together wonderfully in 1998
and became one of snipe's signature
roles some mother
is always trying to ice skater bill
many attempts were made to bring the
x-men to the big screen before the 2000
adaptation
perhaps the closest anyone came to
actually getting it done was in 1990
when stan lee and marvel writer chris
claremont pushed an x-men feature to
james cameron
and his then-wife director catherine
bigelow cameron agreed to produce the
flick with bigelow set to direct and the
screenplay was commissioned from gary
goldman the writer behind the big
trouble in little china and total recall
that script titled wolverine and the
x-men would have seen wolverine
recruiting kitty pride for charles
xavier's team
the story revolved around the group
coming into conflict with a presidential
candidate named thomas prince who oddly
enough had the powers of magneto
probably a coincidence well it's
complicated
cameron's choice for the part of
wolverine was actually pretty inspired
bob hoskins
while hoskins is far from the huge
jacked man who eventually would come to
define the role on screen
it could easily be argued that the
starkey who framed roger rabbit star had
a more comics accurate look
according to claremont the project went
nowhere largely because cameron was more
interested in another marvel property
spider-man for which he had a very
detailed and deeply strange script
of course the director's marvel dreams
went unfulfilled but things still ended
up working out for him just fine
as hard as it is to believe famous
shlockmeisters cannon films briefly
acquired the rights to spider-man in the
80s when don copperloft marvel's film
agent at the time
literally couldn't get any other studios
to bite cannon had big plans for their
movie eyeing tom cruise for the title
role
bob hoskins for the part of doctor
octopus and texas chainsaw massacre
filmmaker toby hooper for the director's
chair
when hooper passed they tapped joseph
zito whose most successful previous
credit had been friday the 13th
the final chapter which is actually one
of the better friday the 13th movies
though nowhere near the final one
eventually they cast stuntman scott
leather in the title role and produced a
teaser that was little more than a proof
of concept real
nowhere near able to actually make the
movie yet the studio hoped to use a
teaser as an investor magnet to acquire
funds
to make the actual film when investors
failed to kick down the door producers
slashed the film's budget in half
prompting zito to depart
the subsequent failure of canon's
notoriously cheap looking superman for
the quest for peace
as well as the expense of producing the
he-man movie masters of the universe
ended up sinking the company cannon
spider-man slipped into limbo perhaps
the biggest bullet the wall crawler
ever dodged check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superhero movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one